ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show back here in uh in our home
in Dubai uh broadcasting from the United
Arab Emirates for tax purposes
um very excited to be with you go and
watch that Colin Quinn episode it's a
great episode uh we talk a lot about
comedy uh so far 14 people have watched
it and enjoyed it so if you could be the
15th that would really be helpful uh
subscribe rate review like
I don't know tweet text
um and uh we're back we're back we're
still on the road we've got a few days
Chicago Theaters almost sold out in
Chicago the Masonic in San Francisco we
have some seats left and it's because
people are very scared about parking
their car and walking to the theater in
San Francisco because they recently just
had to call in the National Guard
to deal with the um fentanyl uh and uh
homeless epidemic in San Francisco
hey I mean listen I understand that but
let's be honest you're a [__] [__]
if you can't deal with that for a few
blocks it's a few blocks
get as close as you can
bring a bat and walk for three blocks
with a bat and then leave the bat and
then come in the theater
it's fine most people are not going to
be maimed going to that show someone
will
that's the that's statistic that's
unfortunately someone walking the show
is going to get maimed and maybe
permanently I don't know lose an eye
look at this scar
someone but I it's the likelihood that
it's you is almost nothing it will be
someone might be a couple
someone walking to my show in San
Francisco is gonna get it
but it's so rare that it would be you to
not want to go it's so statistically
it's almost impossible that it's going
to be you they're going to pick up like
it's gonna be a big group of people
moving towards the venue and then
they're just gonna pick off the people
on the sides of the group have you ever
seen Lions the way they so it's not a
big thing
um and we've got that we have a casino
in
uh but out an hour from San Diego I mean
we've
come to that maybe
um I wanted to talk about this um
because this is sad
um uh an Uber Eats driver was
dismembered
um in Florida and Florida is it's being
sold to everybody as the state and I
love parts of Florida there's parts of
Florida that I love Palm Beach
now but the red there is a rest of it
now obviously that Miami is great and
I'm kidding the West Coast Tampa and
Saint Pete oh that's great but you do
have to remember that 90 of Florida
geographically is an unlivable hell
where things go on
and it's not it's not a political
statement I'm not like and it's Rhonda
Santa says fault no it's just this is a
place where people eat each other
this is a place where there is you know
behavior that is biblical biblical
Behavior where you look at it and you go
this is something I don't even
understand I don't even understand this
Chicago we get it the shootings you're
on my block I'm on your block boom boom
you know there's maybe a little more but
not that much Florida's like I'm gonna
dismember someone I'm gonna dissolve
them in a bathtub uh I'm gonna choke a
pit bull things you don't think about
you know you don't think about someone
choking a pit bull but people do and
they do it in Florida a demonic MS-13
gang member by the way I'm not saying
that the New York Post is so I have no
issue with the salvadorians uh demonic
MS-13 gang member robbed and dismembered
an Uber each driver in Florida for no
apparent reason last week Oscar Solas 30
who moved to the Sunshine State
in January after being sprung on parole
from Indiana allegedly yanked Randall
crook
60 and was home on April 19th and
butchered him
God cook was making his final delivery
of the night
and that should be the Eli Roth movie at
the next one I do called the final
delivery
Eli Roth will call me he'll be like so
there's a movie called final it's called
final delivery and it's based on the
MS-13 driver who's uh dismembered in his
home
um so he's just a guy trying to make a
living for his family that's what
they're all saying
and
he brings him in the house and then he
chops them up what would what would
motivate
someone to do that
how late
was this guy can we look at that is
there a is there because I've gotten
delivery I ordered delivery once from a
Mexican restaurant and it was so it had
moved around so much in the car when you
opened it up the guacamole was all on
the top like the roof of the styrofoam
and there was just like one Taquito see
I didn't even know where the rest of
them were there are
there are like mitigating factors I
think to this where it's like and by the
way what was the order can we do we know
the or can we find out the order
the final delivery but this is what I
mean you know months ago I talked about
the gig economy being a horror movie
what the gig economy is is you're just
out there hoping someone doesn't kill
you that's really what it is you're
hoping to God the person who gets into
your Uber or walks into Walmart doesn't
shoot you eat you maim you because as
the drugs get more potent and as the
people that are doing these things are
just out in the open and they deal
directly with you you're they're at your
doorstep they're handing you food you're
sitting in the back of a car and and you
know they're sitting in the back of your
car and you're driving them to their who
knows they're you know so at the end of
the day it's like the gig economy which
is you know the the delivery and the
Uber and things like that let alone the
uh department stores where you're a
Sitting Duck you're literally sitting
there these things have just this
increased likely Hood now that one of
them is going to end incredibly bad
incredibly Ben you read about them all
the time you read about these all the
time where you're driving an Uber and
then somebody gets in
and you wonder if someone knows like do
you know you wonder if somebody knows
because people say they get premonitions
before they die this is what people say
does someone know when they accept this
delivery and they go to I'm going to say
El Pollo Loco because I missed our team
but I don't know it might have been
Italian I don't know do they know when
they pick up that food and when they're
driving to this guy's house do they feel
a little bit in the pit of their stomach
like this could be maybe this is it
maybe this is the last Taquito I drop
off this might be the last burrito I
hand a guy what a horrible way to die
you just hand them food and then he
Yanks you the way the article was
written he Yanks you in and now you're
in his lair you're in the dungeon now
that's how you get kids to pay attention
in school go sure you could do Uber Eats
but I'll tell you you might get yanked
into the lair of an MS-13 guy who eats
you
so do you want to do your homework or
not
what are they saying here so they've
asked the wife but she didn't share the
details of it well why
seems pretty personal yeah
so he was dismembered
and the guy's been charged with felony
murder
um
last delivery of the night though of
course but this is what they're saying
they're saying he wasn't in his right
mind he was probably on drugs this is
what they are saying I mean these people
look
you know like good people here this is
bring the get that up there that's
really really sad this is crazy what are
you doing Uber Eats for in Florida I
know people have to and that's the
comments I'm gonna go oh you're out of
touch
you got the Fourteen thousand dollar
sunglasses you're out of touch you don't
understand it people have to do who
breeds I know but
do ya is there nothing else to do look
at that that's who you're delivering
food to
bring that up
that's who you're there should be a
photo of him
on the delivery where you go no I'm not
bringing a burrito to him he's gotta get
it if you do that to your face you have
to go out and get your food if you do
that you should you are not getting home
delivery
I'm not bringing you an eggs benedict at
9am you have to go out and get your food
through a drive to you I mean that's
nuts summer's coming are you ready to
unveil the beach pod manscape is here to
ensure your body is fully ready for that
for the for the wild with their
game-changing full-body grooming and
hygiene products don't be the guy at the
beach with Austin Powers chest hair if
you grew more winter men I don't even
know anymore just buy it
I've had enough buy it I'm telling you
right now here's what it is
it's a groomer for your balls and your
penis and your uh man's pubis which is
the area above your penis uh and uh your
[__] maybe and the uh taint uh listen
just buy it it's the best there's two
groomers on the market there's this and
the wall and the wall one sucks this is
a lot better it's one of the things that
if you need it and you use code Tim D
you get 20 off plus free shipping with
the code Tim D at manscape.com who
wouldn't want that who doesn't need that
you enjoy the show manscape.com promo
code Tim D 20 off free shipping
you shave your dick
capisce you got it there's not there's
the the pitch here is do you want to
shave your private parts your genitals
you need to do it use my code twenty
percent off manscape.com Tim d i
everyone I know uses it
I love it
manscape.com
20 off free shipping code Tim D shave
your balls so now in Coachella this was
interesting because Coachella just
passed and um
it's always good at Coachella to see a
40 year old comedians going I have a
ticket is there anywhere I can stay
is there anywhere I can stay can someone
house me I'm going to Coachella I'm 60.
can someone house me I'm elderly
I've left my family to go to Coachella
does anyone have a floor I can plop on
now Coachella is a festival in the
desert where there is music and uh
people are let loose because there's not
enough time in our society to really
just let loose and relax and there's not
enough music festivals in my opinion
that's a big problem and these are young
usually good or decent looking people
that are out there living the California
Dream this is the California Dream it's
being on drugs being uh outside and
being uh in the presence of celebrities
that's the thing that's what the dream
is I'm on drugs I'm outside and someone
famous is that way that's why this state
exists and Coachella is a distillation
of that people going and I'm dressed
like a Native American I'm a white
person dressed in wacky Garb I'm in a
mud pit and I'm uh there's Nicki Minaj
that's what it is and I haven't been I'd
like to go I want to see it I'm not
above it I'm sure it's very enjoyable uh
but I haven't gone I'm always working
I'm working I can't do it but
um all of these people that went the
people at Coachella supposedly somebody
somebody went and asked them how much
money they make and if their ticket was
worth it and uh I guess this was uh
so the ticket cost about five hundred
dollars
is there a video of this
oh no this is just a uh like a opinion
piece or you know sort of like a feature
thing just photos of the people with
therapy Danielle made 37 her pronouns
are I'm sorry now Daniella's 37 years
old her pronouns are she her
her income is two hundred and ten
thousand I'm a rich Auntie I'm a single
woman in the world well that sounds fun
nothing sounds funner than that 210
Grand Rich antium a single woman in the
world we're worth it
here's what she said
I like the diversity of the artists
what
I don't even know
I like that I'm not crowded or
overwhelmed even the food I would say is
worth it like today we're having chicken
fingers but yesterday we had fantastic
dumplings
I mean all these people's brains have
been broken
I like the diversity of the artist even
the food's good chicken fingers
dumplings they got it all
I mean
it's very organized we were talking
about like how East Coast festivals
people are kind of pushy nobody pushed
me once
I have not been pushed I can eat my
chicken fingers in peace without being
pushed and it's only five hundred
dollars
maybe people run into you walking and
stuff like that well that's what they
that's what it is no one's pushing you
what do you mean on East Coast festivals
people are just like hey [__] and then
pushing you
but we were pretty far up for Calvin
Harris I didn't feel any surge of the
crowd everyone is just nice Gabriel
Vieira pronoun shihar
27 this is gonna be the age 27 27 to 37.
lives in New York City makes 80 000
first time at Coachella worth it
honestly we've gone to a few other
festivals and this does feel a lot more
organized and spacious I'm very happy to
be here
well that was detailed Rolando Garcia
pronouns he they
age 26 lives in Austin Texas of course
occupation none
no income unless you count mommy and
daddy first time in Coachella yes
worth it Rolando says yeah
I've had a great time I've been doing
festivals for years and I feel like this
is a festival on easy mode because
everyone is so nice no one's up against
you for any reason what are other music
festivals like I mean how lazy are these
people what are other music like are
other music festivals just mosh pits and
fights where people are berating
everyone's like this one's easy I'm a
career Music Festival goer and uh
Bonnaroo is tough
bonnaroo's hard Austin City Limits
goddamn nightmare
um
he goes worth it yeah I had a great time
I could just walk up to the front for
any reason okay
Alec Mitchell pronounce he him
now by the way not to belabor the
pronoun Point here but like
I don't understand the pronouns of this
article does that mean that they think
people are reading this article and then
they're gonna reference it
foreign
like it's only for me right it's only
for people making fun of it that's
exclusively for podcasters who are
making fun of
he's 25 years old
occupation he's currently studying for
the bar he's going to be a lawyer he
does not have any income none of these
people by the way two of the four have
no income they're at Coachella it's 500
a ticket no income
this is the thing people it's amazing
American society
it's his fourth time at Coachella with
no income he's gone four times
worth it now remember remember no income
as I read this no income it's a super
unique experience and I really like it
because it's one of the only places
where you can unplug
for three days what's he unplugging from
I never checked my text or anything
uh Alec I don't know where you are but
your mother's very sick
Alec Alec please answer your mother's
very sick you had mentioned something
about going into the desert I don't know
I don't know if that's I know it's not
work related because you know you don't
work and we don't judge you for that we
know we know the bar is very hard and
you've been studying for it for years
and years and years but I mean there are
a lot of other people that work their
way through the bar and I'm not bringing
it up but your mother's very very sick
and we don't know what it is the doctor
thinks it's a stroke uh so if you could
please just get back to us
um he goes I never checked my text or
anything it's just so fast paced so it's
really good for decompressing even
though it's a crazy weekend I'm mostly
going with the expectation to just go
with the flow it can be really hectic so
I think getting a good group of friends
and just sort of sticking with them and
accommodating what everyone really wants
to see is the best way to go about it
that's right Alec
Dylan Boda 25 years old she her La
advertising 90 grand a year fifth time
at Coachella fifth
worth it I honestly think this was the
best one yet I don't know if that's just
because I'm older and more experienced
and know how to do it
the setting is amazing because the
desert is just beautiful and obviously
going with a big group of friends you're
making memories that you're just never
going to forget and it's just total
freedom nothing to focus on but music
for three days by the way every
explanation here has been the most basic
[__]
explanation of why you would enjoy
anything no one's hitting me these are
adults it's like why are you enjoying
Coachella they're like I can walk around
in the field and no one says well hey
why don't you have a job
no one says what are you doing with your
life it's the most basic [__] reason to
enjoy anything this is why like children
enjoy things Marco Salazar he him 34
lives in San Diego software developer
makes more than six figures it's his
17th year Coachella God bless give it up
for Marco 17.
worth it yeah because I've been coming
here since I was like 17 or 18. it's
kind of like a formative thing for me I
love coming out to the desert I've lived
nearby my entire life so it's kind of
like revisiting that time when I
discovered music and I'm discovering
more and more new artists every time all
right well that's nice
Ed Benda age 32 lives in Los Angeles
pronouns he him Works in film makes
money more than six figures
I think we're just really excited to
have this experience together he went
with someone named Molly maybe that's a
drug or maybe that's his lady I think
it's his lady yeah we're big gorillas
fans uh personally and that was a ton of
fun and then it was really cool to see
Chromeo we were dancing into the night
this was awesome Molly Benda that's his
check she's like this is the best one so
far it helps when you're with someone
you love we're excited to see Frank
Ocean but also just exploring some new
music well I'm glad everyone's happy I'm
glad everyone was happy
yeah I mean these get worse and worse by
the way 43 marketing
uh having the scheduled area in the VIP
entrance for parking makes to walk
shorter
Georgia 17 she her San Diego student
definitely we met Anderson pack in VIP
okay
Charlize zagabond 23 30 grand personal
assistant second time
I think it was everyone's here for the
same thing have a good time I've only
been twice and I've camped both times
it's fun overall
they've interviewed everyone at
Coachella the Biden Administration is
doing something which I like I think
this is good I usually you know I have
my issues with them with uh them
constantly trying to drum up a nuclear
war
with the rest of the countries with
China and Russia I'm again find that
objectionable for a few reasons
um but what what they're doing which is
good now this seems like it's not good
but Biden is Raising costs for home
buyers with good credit to help risky
Borrowers is a great idea this is a
great idea I remember I was around and I
was in business when we started to look
at people who couldn't really afford
houses and say no it's your time
it's your time actually and I and
there's a lot of money to be made there
until there's not but I'm I'm really for
this because people that have good
credit and that have borrowed money and
paid it back should be punished so that
dirt bags and derelicts can get more
that seems fair
home buyers with good credit scores will
soon be facing higher mortgage fees as
the Biden Administration seeks to close
the racial homeownership Gap and get
more first time and low-income buyers
through the door
a new federal rule could raise the
monthly mortgage payments of buyers with
good credit scores well why make it
about rate it's always about race with
these people never it's never not about
race
it's always about well we have to clear
we have to close the racial
homeownership cap okay but if you give
people houses they can't afford remember
when you did that we did that we did
that
that was the subprime mortgage and why
do you think we did that the community
reinvestment act it was the same thing
we want to close the gap
and no one closes the gap
in in an effective way they just give
sham mortgages to people and disguise
the mortgages so that people think they
can afford them up until they can
um in the short term this may increase
homeownership among the targeted group
but I'm afraid it could decrease home
ownership uh uh among the middle class
Jerry Howard said
only about you see this is all things
that we're trying to do here I think
it's good ideally to like obviously you
want more people to own houses
um but I don't I don't know if [__]
over people that have paid their bills
is the right way to do it that seems odd
that seems like a strange
way to do it
I don't know so they're gonna they're
gonna charge
certain people less
so that they could get them into houses
and
you know here's the deal
I think that there's deeper structural
problems with why Black and Hispanic
people don't have the type of uh down
payments and you should try to address
those and I'm not saying you shouldn't
have programs for them as first-time
homebuyers but this is exactly why we
had a subprime mortgage crisis because
Wall Street which has no morality was
like great because all they needed was
the directive they were like get more
people in the homes well she's like
great good done and then they were like
how about this negative amortization
loan you pay your mortgage but it gets
bigger how about this pick a payment
loan you there's four options for you to
pay you know how about a two percent
loan that balloons to eight percent like
all of these products that Wall Street
came up with were be was supposedly
cloaked again and like altruism like
let's do the right thing so I'm not
against this in theory but you got to
realize in practice it did destroy the
economy once in 2008 it was literally
the impetus we're doing the same thing
we're going but it's like it would be
like today if somebody said I think we
should research his diseases in China
let's put a lab in China where we
weaponize like imagine there was a
disease like a respiratory Illness but
it was really bad let's put it lab in
China and let's experiment on like I
don't know bats or other things let's
manipulate the viruses to see how bad
they could really get and let's hope
nothing gets out that's literally what
this is that's like suggesting a disease
a coronavirus research program today
that's really what it comes down to like
these are the things
that [__] everybody up
and the real estate market right now is
kind of bottoming a little bit it's kind
of jumping back now that doesn't mean
that there isn't some more blood in the
water
the efforts get more low-income
Americans in America to color into
homeownership is essentially being
subsidized by borrowers who have better
credit scores it can contribute to their
down payment
yeah if you worked hard and you saved
money for a home and you could pay the
loan back the fact that you have to pay
more money for your house
is ludicrous
it penalizes Americans for having good
credit I mean that just unless there's
something about this I don't understand
which is always possible I'm reacting to
these things in real time
um
I don't understand also when all these
people are in the houses and then they
look at the price of fuel and the price
of food and the price of putting gas in
their car and the price of uh everything
else then what happens what about energy
costs what about all that stuff how what
is it just we just kept them in the
house and then go enjoy
you know what about all the other stuff
they're not going to be able to pay for
I think then they'll probably go okay
well then we're gonna do those things
too
if listen not everybody needs to own a
house obviously more minorities should
own houses I agree with that principled
of course but not everybody's ready to
own a house that's the reality well you
own like a bunch of houses why would you
yeah yeah but only when I'm only until I
was ready I had a house that I lost
cause I wasn't ready
because I wasn't ready and I took a
mortgage I shouldn't have taken so I
know how this goes you could have given
me here's the deal people don't realize
that you can give people money off and
make it easier for them they still might
not be ready to oh now it's a
case-by-case basis you can't just throw
a house at somebody and go there you go
enjoy because then you know what happens
they're living in it and and then
they're they're there and they're
getting angrier and angrier because they
can't afford it and then they kill an
Uber Eats driver they yank an Uber Eats
driver into their house and dismember
them because they shouldn't have been
there
right what else do we got I don't really
know uh
I just I just think it's a little it's a
little tough out there when you're just
swamping people
swapping people
with money the blue check thing on
Twitter folks I don't even people like
why don't you have a blue track I don't
even know my password I have to log in
I can't even get into my password I
can't figure it out
I gotta reset it it's a whole problem
it I I don't I don't carry the way I
mean the blue check might be good it
might not be good
the Twitter's over anyway it's it's not
this is not in its Heyday Twitter's not
it's heyday
um
but there's a lot of impersonating
accounts now because this model is weird
where you can just buy a blue check I
guess the governor of New York
um so this is a fake account Kathy
hochel
okay so Kathy hotel is Democrat right
yes so they had this in Kathy Ultra
Republican for New York Kathy ochel has
fought to make gas green protect the
rights to evict and keep Rikers full
she's bravely stood up to voters
Democrats in Albany and in Congress now
we're proud to announce Kathy's campaign
for Republican governor of New York so
this is fun where people are coming in
and they're impersonating people and
they're writing fun tweets and this is
chaos this is the kind of the gates of
hell that have been Unleashed by this
new policy where you can buy because the
old policy was just they would verify
certain people and not others they'd
verify like journalists no matter who
they were you have 400 followers you're
in Brooklyn you you know you're writing
on a Blog you got verified so people got
angry rightfully so
and now Elon Musk is like all right well
let's let's just pay eight dollars pay
dollars to have your stupid opinion
heard with a blue check and then there's
people in America like Stephen King
where he gave them the blue checks back
and they're like I didn't pay for the
blue check I didn't pay for the blue and
then they're like Eli should donate my
blue check the money for my blue check
he should donate my blue check to
charity
he should donate my money to charge all
the while this is happening we are the
closest to war with China we've ever
been we are the closest to war with
China that we have ever been and people
are going donate one out of every four
kids in this country goes to bed hungry
and and we have Stephen King going
donate my check to charity if you want
to change something
if you want to make a positive change
don't even write eight dollars a month
for my check to charity this is exactly
how this country should end and is
ending people arguing about who has a
blue check whether they should pay for a
blue think of the dystopian nightmare
that we're gonna people are like
fighting with each other all day why
don't you have a blue check well I I
should have a blue check but I shouldn't
have to pay like it's just a crazy thing
we all agree the website's trash and by
the way not because it's Elon not
because it's free speech none of that
it's just a bad way to communicate
Twitter's an awful way to commute it's
an awful way to have a meaningful
discussion there's it's never happened
I've never seen one meaningful
discussion on Twitter been on it 10
years I've never seen more I've never
seen one discussion where I went Ah
that's good I feel smarter for that it
is awful it's just awful it's like
Facebook
awful it's awful you know these things
have their moment then we realize how
bad it is it's like oh my God I'm
uploading photos of my house I have
photos of my family on Facebook I'm
connected with somebody I knew in
kindergarten on Facebook and we're
fighting about health care it's bad when
these things come out they all come out
for the same reason everybody's trying
to get [__] that's why most of these
things come out people are trying to
meet each other network oh you got a
boat I'd like to go on your boat and
then 10 years later they all descended
what they are which is just people
calling each other pedophiles or Nazis
that's what it is so it can be fun I'll
fire off a fun troll tweet it's fun some
of the things they do are funny on there
but this idea that people are arguing
about the tracks and who has the checks
what they could be you know and then you
see the guys with a blue check now he's
got 200 followers and a blue check
he's got 200 followers he's got he's got
a blue check
and you know it's none of it none of it
really matters
well Twitter's the Town Square well God
help us if that's the case Christ helped
us
and I like what Elon did when he let
people on that shouldn't have been on
that shouldn't have been banned because
they were like hey maybe don't get 19
boosters kids
people's you know playing soccer their
hearts are exploding and the media is
going well we don't you know it's a
routine heart attack
he's 19. it's a routine heart attack
well he if he had covered he would have
had that heart attack because that's
their argument now well it's actually
the study say the studies say
the debt aneurysm he had to kill them if
uh if he had had covert it would have
been much worse
that would have been much worse that
stroke he suffered at 22. man
see from covet it would have been much
worse but because it it maybe it's from
the vet like they're now even they're
not even kind of admitting some of this
maybe from the vaccine they're like well
yeah it might be but it would have been
worse if he had gotten coveted
yeah sure his heart exploding was bad
but if he had got coveted do you know
what would have happened to him God it
would have been bad because they're
they're they're they're admitting now
that that we're what's his name fauci
Trudeau they're all coming out you know
Trudeau the PM of Canada found she's
like I didn't lock anybody down and then
Trudeau's like we never told you to get
this thing so it's a complete
gaslighting of the America by the way I
remember I'm old enough to remember that
when if you didn't have the vaccine
people were treating you like a
pedophile
like you showed up to the party going
where are the kids they treated you like
that and now everybody's gaslighting you
into believe going like no no we never
even no no no no that was up to you dude
it was up to you
here's how much it wasn't up to you if
you even suggested as I did that it
remain up to people people went nuts
that was my position I go true because I
didn't know about the vaccine I know
more now but I didn't know that I just
went choose based on your risk
I took it I've been fat I've been a
smoker I've been a junkie I've been a
drunk I go I guess I'll take that I've
taken a lot of things I'll take that now
that was my but if I even said how about
you choose what's right for you people
are like no yeah you're making it and
now literally all the people who told
you to get it go no no no no no no no no
no we don't we don't even that was like
a thing
that was it that what we didn't I don't
even know
so I mean that that's the issue what
else is going on in this beautiful world
that we live in very excited for
uh these shows
coming up uh and then we're getting off
the road for a while
which I'm also happy about as well you
know the other thing I want to talk
about is Tucker Tucker is gone from Fox
I think he'll come back on the internet
he will be I texted his producer I was
booked kind of to do that show
um they wanted me on that show and I was
gonna do that show and obviously
Tucker has been uh taken out right Fox
did not like him uh you know Murdoch uh
had issues with him could have been over
Dominion might have been over his
private statements might have been
personal you know people forget people
have personal issues with other people
but
he's gone my mother is like doesn't know
what's going on my mother's in a mental
institution and loves Tucker loves her
and I'm not saying all his fans are in a
man I'm not trying to
um I'm not trying to say that but my
mother is so distraught over this she
doesn't know what's going on she doesn't
know Rupert Murdoch why he would fire
him my mother suspects it has to do with
his Chinese wife
is Murdoch's wife Chinese she used to be
right I think she is because my mother's
not up on his new wife but my mother
goes I think he Rupert Murdoch he goes
she goes he's with a Chinese person
correct Chinese porn and I said yeah she
goes well that's that's what we have we
got a problem
I mean now of of course this isn't
Rupert Murdoch is no longer with that
person but this was my mother's idea
about
perhaps what had gone wrong
um but I listen Tucker we welcome Tucker
to the internet I'm sure he will be able
to
go and do whatever he wants but the
Murdoch's have him under a contract like
a really uh I don't know a contract
where he's still technically on they're
still technically paying him it might
limit what he can do but he's got a
lawyer now one of my favorite things
about getting a box of Awesome from
bespoke post every month is how it
sneaks up on you you forget that it's
coming and then boom one day it's there
and you get all kinds of cool stuff you
can take a quiz uh who are you into what
are you about are you a camper do you
like even Outdoorsman are you a
bartender you like Mixology what are you
into do you like cooking in the
wilderness are you a traveling man do
you need some grooming products all of
this can be available in your box of
Awesome from camping gear to cookout
must-haves to drink game upgrades box of
awesome I mean you know who this is
great for for everybody but number one
is for everyone it's for every person's
life on Earth but also somebody's going
away to college this is it this is
actually the gift
if you're a son or daughter or whoever
else
it's going away to college this is the
thing you got them they get a box every
month I'm telling you they go nuts they
go [__] nuts about it they go now I I
took a quiz and the box I got
okay
I took a quiz and because with the
quizzes is
um
the quiz is it's supposed to be like
what are you into and what's going to
get you excited
okay
I I took a quiz from box of Awesome
they send me a box back I open it up
and it has it's it's it's pancake mix
and Derek chauvin's badge
how do they know me how do they know me
like I don't know how they know it
box of awesome dot comment to the code
Tim Dylan at checkout box of awesome.com
Tim Dillon 20 off your first box box of
awesome.com code Tim Dylan all right now
this is sad um and this is you know
we've always tried to handle this issue
with like uh tact on this show because a
lot of people don't I don't want to live
in a right-wing a Christian theocracy
this is not what I want to live in
here's what I also don't want
um what I don't want is uh
children
um you know
using
puberty blocking hormones
or having surgery
uh and then possibly later in life
really regretting that or saying you
know what I never knew what could have
been because I made these choices when I
was very young there seems to be a rush
um that children that are trans or
feeling like they are Transit have some
type of uh you know dysphoria
potentially are being rushed into
operating rooms or they're being rushed
into doctors offices gender reassignment
clinics and stuff like that I do think
that there's a rut it's a little bit of
a rush it's a rush
you know I've always I've always come
from the perspective of like when you're
you can do whatever you want
uh you know
within reason if we can ship you off to
war if you can vote if you can do all
these things you should be able to
change your gender if you like this is
really sad though because there are this
was an 18 year old and unfortunately
stuff happens uh even at that age
because now I agree that this person
should have been allowed to do this but
this is a this is a tragic death one of
the participants in a Dutch study
[Music]
um
it's really sad 18 year old trans
identified male whose puberty was
blocked by the Dutch researchers at a
very early stage meaning there wasn't
enough penile tissue for surgeons to use
to create the new Vagina therefore a
more risky procedure using a section of
the patient's bowel was necessary which
resulted in
necrotizing fasciitis which is a
flesh-eating bacteria
um
and by the way
and I'm not trying to take a side here
in the culture War but this is
the plot of Frozen three
and I don't understand why
because the plot of Frozen three
is about someone who
sadly tragically dies because their
bowel vagina
got deceased
I thought Frozen was about snowmen and a
nice uh castle princess queen thing
but it's not
it's about someone's bowel
being made into a vagina
and that vagina got diseased and they
died
and that's Frozen three
so maybe I don't think it's funny
that children who go to Sea who's in
Olaf
the Snowman have to sit through a
two-hour movie
about a vagina being made out of
someone's bowel because they don't have
penile tissue because their puberty was
blocked in a young a this is the I'm not
lying this is Frozen three
and I just think it's it's too much for
kids to deal with at this time
you can be whatever you want to be but
if you don't have enough penal tissue
because we blocked your puberty we're
gonna use your bowel that's the thing
that you used to go to the bathroom and
we're gonna make a vagina but it might
get sick
that that's one of the songs and by the
way I don't even think that as a song I
don't think that's well written
I don't think that's well written I'm a
fan of alliteration and metaphor and
it's that's very direct
and it's unfortunate
this is not right that this happened
because now I guess that a few years are
going to be better at this isn't that
the hope
isn't that the hope
in a few now this is a fair question
don't get mad at me the question is in a
few years are we going to be better at
bowel vagina surgeries yes or no
are we going to be better at making a
vagina out of someone's bowel I hope we
are literally not kidding no joke I
genuinely hope getting a vagina in a few
years is like nothing
it's like remember the dentist it was
kind of annoying that's what I hope it
is I don't want anybody dying if you
want a vagina they should be able to
give you a [__] puss and it should be
quick it is gonna be what it what will
it be at that point 20 20 30 25 20 27 20
30. in 2030 if you're dying because they
can't put a puss on you
we got a problem
so they need to figure this out
without people getting necrotizing
fasciitis
and I don't think it should be
the plot of Frozen three because now in
Frozen three they lie and at the end
uh the necrotizing fasciitis is cured by
the magic of the land which isn't real
that's not real
but at the end the the bowel vagina is
cured and the person is free
what do you mean Jesus this is the plot
of the film this was leaked from Disney
leaked this I don't even know why they
leaked this I think because they want to
have the fight now
what if Disney had a ride called bowel
vagina the ride
where kids could see because here's the
deal this it's it some of this is a
little freaky but some of it's cool
some of it's cool that you can make a
[__] out of a lot of stuff
I think it's gonna be like how a bill
becomes a law remember that if this is
how a bill becomes a lot I think it's
gonna have to be like this is how a
[__] becomes a [__] and they're gonna
have to talk about it because I don't
want people dying this is [__]
horrible
I don't want people dying I want them to
figure out how to make better [__]
America
figure out how to make a better [__]
the [__] you gotta get a better [__]
program for the kids gotta get a better
[__] program for the kids I do not want
my son's [__] infected
I do not want my son's [__] infected
and if you can't give my son
the [__] of his dreams
if you can't give my son listen to me
medical community
if you can't give my son a [__] he's
proud of
that I don't if I can't look at my son's
[__] without feeling a little bit of
Pride I don't want to deal I don't want
to be involved I don't want to be
involved because that's sick
that's sick
if you give my son a [__] that's gross
and green and diseased
I'm gonna be mad as a father
as a dad as a gay dad who adopted a son
who wants a [__] if we just follow this
to its logical conclusion me and my
husband have adopted a kid who ends up
being trans and we're dealing with it
and he comes home and he goes I gotta
puss and we're like great and then he's
like here it is and we're all looking at
his [__] uh at Christmas and his
sister's like oh my God that's gross put
it away and I'm like shut up he
accomplished that and then I look at it
and I'm like the lips are green
the lips of your [__] are green
and my son goes Dad shut up uh I think
they know what they're doing
and I'm like yeah maybe they do but like
maybe trust your old man a little bit
how about you trust your old man a
little bit on this
I used to you know before I decided I I
wanted cogs in my mouth I used to [__]
around the ladies and I never saw a
green puss
I saw some flaps I didn't love down
there but I never saw a green plus can
you trust your old man here and my
husband's going honey can you stop
honey can you stop it probably goes away
after a few days I'm like like they told
us the fireplace did we had to burn it
for eight hours and then the smell of
gas goes away I'm telling you you got a
problem here son you got a problem you
got a green puss and I want to take you
back and he goes nope [__] you I'm like
whatever and then in two days he wakes
up and it's worse it's bad and I'm like
I told you and now my son's [__]
is being ravaged by necrotizing
fasciitis my son's vagina that I paid
for and he's proud of and we love we
love
we love our son's [__]
and I and then my neighbor says what's
going on and I go you my son
his [__]
because I still but it's daughter but I
still can't it's hard for me to say
because I just keep forgetting because
he was my son for many years so I just
and he's okay with it my son is actually
okay with it he's like Dad I get it I'm
I'm very Chi now but I get it's okay so
I that's what I'm talking and I go I'm
talking to I'm like you know you know
Ralph's [__] is Scream any in my
neighborhood didn't you just get that
[__] I go he just got that [__] but
the thing is you know we put Ralph on
puberty blockers who he didn't have
enough penis tissue to make the [__]
they had to use his bowel and they go of
course
and then it's like you know Long Island
someone's like you know Ralph's having
problems with his bowel [__] this is a
problem so I'm just letting you know
because my son also wants a [__] and
we're not doing it out of his bow we're
doing small intestine
Noel Tim Dillon's son had a bow [__]
now he's got an advertising for shitis
so we're taking a small part of the
small intestine for our son's [__]
folks I know people might be offended by
this what I'm trying to say is that I
want better [__] I want better
[__] for the for the and I want
better [__] for the ladies that want
[__] if you want I want a hard thick
[__] [__] for my daughter
if my dog I wanna I want a beautiful Aid
is a little too much but a seven like a
seven seven and a half uh nice big [__]
that's perfectly pink and thick and
round with two nice balls I want that
for my daughter
and if they don't know how to make a
[__] for my daughter
if my daughter comes home with a rotten
[__]
Because by the way folks this is what's
gonna happen you're not winning with
this stuff you're just not gonna win
your children are going to have [__]
and [__] for Christmas you're not
going to win you're probably not going
to win I don't know
I think I think it's a little wacky too
I think adults should be able to do what
they want but it's just what it's gonna
you're gonna be getting your kids [__]
and [__] for Christmas there's no way
around it in 10 years you're going to be
giving your daughter a cow a realistic
[__] and she's gonna open it thank you
and you're gonna go tomorrow we go down
to the clinic and get it sewed on and
she's gonna be happy because this is
what it's going to be and I want the
best for my kids so I want my daughter
to have a big thick [__] if she wants
and I want my son to have a [__] if he
wants but we have to do better by the
kids with the with the materials we use
we have to use better materials
to make the [__]
and that's that's true this is real no
one should be getting angry at me I know
that people are going to get angry at
this and they're gonna go you know this
is actually a very serious issue and
you're trivializing it but I'm actually
not I'm actually saying you can't build
a [__] out of battles you got to use
better material to build my son's [__]
if my son wants a [__] I want him to
have a good one I want it to be wet
I want it to be wet I want my son to
have a wet [__]
I want I want that you think I want my
son to have some draw like a dry puss
a dry [__]
I want my son's [__] to be so wet
that when he gets up from the chair on
Christmas dinner he leaves a trail like
a snail
like a snail
here's the thing can I even do the show
anymore because it's like can you
satirize any of this anymore
where can can you make jokes about it
like could what would what I don't even
know anymore like how do you how do you
heighten any of this
how do you make any of this you know how
do you make any of this funny without
you know I don't know anymore I truly
it's like we're we're at a point pretty
soon we're like whatever I do whatever
you want to call it what I do political
satire I don't know what you want to
call it social commentary it's almost
becoming in pot the like it's crazy to
even talk about but I'm dead serious
about this
this is a tragedy and I want
I want everyone to be to do the right
thing
this is not good they say they got E
coli you know what salmonella I ate raw
cookie dough once and I went am I gonna
get salmonella from it because of the
egg
but this is what I mean about
risks we take in life I hate raw cookie
dough someone gets a puss
but it shouldn't be a risk you should be
able to transition in a healthy way and
it should be cost effective it shouldn't
be hard
it shouldn't be hard and your family
should be involved
your family should be involved in your
trip like you know what I mean
why wouldn't if you got a new [__]
you'd not show it like there was me and
this kid Dan we were on the road for a
while and we used to say this stuff all
the time and it was really funny we used
to say
we used to say the sentence where we go
don't be too embarrassed to ask your son
to see his [__] and this was we said
that's going to be the quote of like
2021. don't be too embarrassed to ask
your son to see his new [__]
and that's what I think that's the
advice I give to fathers
that's the advice I give to fathers
right now
you know your son has a [__] and you
know he's proud of it ask to see it
asked to see it you're not going to be
aroused you're not sick you're not a
sicko you just want to make sure that
they did the right thing by your son
because you took him in
and they're you know giving him a puss
so he can become your daughter
and you're like I'm cool though that I'm
fine with all that go hey guys guys I'm
good with that I don't care by the way I
wouldn't care a lot of people don't care
if your son becomes a daughter your
daughter becomes says some people care
but you want them to be healthy and
happy and have the best private parts
they can have that can't be
controversial it can't be controversial
to say I want my transgender son or
daughter to have the best fake private
parts they can have
and I'll pay for it I've got money I've
got money to buy a [__] for my daughter
but it's got to be good it can't kill
her
your [__] killed my son
laughs
how many people are gonna have to run
into a medical facility and go
that's gonna be the new Braveheart
I'm just saying
then we got to figure it out
Tim dilloncomedy.com for live shows
tickets and all the stuff that you might
like we'll be back next week or patreon
we will see you on the patreon as well
we're uploading an episode we are back
in the groove of it uh some tickets left
in Palm Beach Charleston Hershey
Pennsylvania Chicago Illinois Milwaukee
Wisconsin funner California San
Francisco and then uh Parks Casino in
September we really appreciate everybody
for listening and I don't want anyone to
get offended by this by the way this
isn't my this isn't my goal my goal is
not to offend my goal is to heal
my goal is to heal to heal the puss my
goal is to heal
I know it's tough I believe there are
trans people I don't want to live in the
you know in the Dark Ages I'm just
saying when we discuss these things it
sounds crazy because some of it's crazy
but maybe it's just new
maybe it's just new and you got to get
over it
maybe you got to get over it and you
just gotta go listen
it is what it is and these are the new
this is the new game these are the new
the new game in town is to is to make
things
easier and better for people and more
convenient and I'm just saying that
if my son if I had a son
and they wanted a vagina I would want
that vagina to be top of the line
and not a diseased wreck
and people are gonna be like no there's
two people gonna get mad at me the
Christian people are like why would you
ever tolerate your son wanting a vagina
I'm like whatever he wants a bus
he feels like a girl he wants a vagina
and then the trans people are like
you're actually making it all about body
parts and you're making it all about
this
and I'm gonna put a little bit is about
the parts
and I just want them to have the Bentley
Flying Spur of [__]
and if that makes me a bad father if it
makes me a bad dad to want my son to
have the top of the line [__]
then I'm a
not to [__] to have
on his person
if that makes me a bad dad
then so be it
but I want nothing more than to be able
to look at my son on Christmas morning
and go
are you happy and when he takes his puss
out and shows the family I go
[__] that's a real [__]
I wish I wasn't a [__] I'd [__] that
[__] right now
and he's like Dad shut up he's like Dad
will you stop
and I it's two years the year is 20 30.
and my husband goes if you stop joking
around about [__] your son's [__]
and I'm like first of all it's my
daughter second of all I'm kidding
this is a joke
and my son like puts his [__] away and
he's like and his non-binary
uh transracial
um
being who's dating comes and picks him
up
who's a demisexual
who's uh you know involved in a
relationship with my daughter
but my son still identifies as he that
is she so I can say son he's like I'll
make it easier for you Dad
and then
his his they they show up and they are
like
oh my God and my son's like
my dad is like joking around about like
wanting to [__] my [__] he's such a
[__] weirdo
and they're like your dad like loves you
he's like really he really like supports
you like do you know how much I wish my
dad
talked about sucking my [__] my dad
didn't even want to see my [__] when I
got it do you know how much how easy it
would be for me if I came home for
Christmas and my father was joking
around about sucking my [__]
but your father because he was a
comedian and he's like a fun guy
he's a fun guy
he's talking to you about [__] your
[__] because he actually took the time
to look at your [__]
and look at it and congratulate you and
affirm you as a person
and my father doesn't even want to
discuss that so maybe I'm not going to
feel too bad for you that your father
has to [__] your [__]
I think that's kind of cool actually
I think that's pretty [__] cool that
your dad did that in front of everybody
that's Christmas
2030 in the Dylan household
I'm I'm telling my son he's got the best
[__] because I worked hard for it I
said I was out there doing shows on tour
buses flying around doing podcasts why
so you can have a fat wet puss
that's why
so that when your girl puts that strap
on and just takes you to town
and that pussy's wet it's like actually
wet it's like a [__] Flume ride at
[__] an amusement park it's because
your father put the time in
do you understand that
that's my [__] I own that [__] I've
given it to you because you're my son
and I love you you're my son and then I
grab his [__]
mm-hmm
I know I just want you to remember
what I did for you I said every time you
touch your [__]
I tell my son this I'm dying now this is
we fast forwarded story
I'm dying from like from six kids at
once doctor's like we've never even seen
this
I'm dying and I'm like every time you
take your [__] out know that I want you
to think of your father
think of me when you take your [__] out
because you got a beautiful [__] and
then my son's a little older now my
son's like well it's not the [__] you
saw back then like I know all [__]
change but they're still beautiful
and then I go to heaven and God goes you
did everything right
because
ironically this is everything you should
have done
typical comedy.com goodbye good night